today on the matt well show democrats
and abortion supporters ranted raved and
cried during a committee hearing on the
texas abortion law yesterday we'll talk
about that also the national school
board association is asking the biden
administration's help in fighting back
against the quote domestic terrorists
who are saying mean things to them
during school board meetings and a
republican congressman says some brave
and necessary things about the family
and responsibility during a hearing
yesterday and plus demi lovato has an
encounter with aliens and a new york
times op-ed argues that divorce is an
act of quote radical self-love we'll
discuss all of that and more today on
the matt well show
[Applause]
well now a quick word from lifelock
listen every time you're on the internet
as you are right now you are putting
yourself in a potentially vulnerable
position because there are a lot of bad
people out there uh who know how to
exploit the internet to really make your
life pretty miserable and there are
other issues as well like payments app
like payment apps like venmo and cash
app and others they make payments easy
but you may want to adjust your privacy
settings to prevent them from sharing
your personal information
because a recent report found that third
parties such as banks and fraud
monitoring services even some marketing
firms may be able to get their hands on
that information it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could harm what's yours your finances
your credit your reputation
everything and that's why it's so good
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats and they
also give you access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you do become
a victim
and so you have you have coverage and
protection on both sides of it look no
one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com
walsh that again is lifelock.com walsh
for 25 off
yesterday the house oversight committee
uh held a hearing about the text
abortion law
now i have been reliably informed that
outsiders should not get involved in the
local politics of states where they
don't live
i solved that problem of course as you
know by moving to virginia so that i
could speak at a school board in
virginia and yet so far as i know none
of the democrats in congress yesterday
delivering tearful and angry speeches
about the texas abortion law have
actually bothered to move there first
that's because as we've seen the outside
agitator rule only ever applies to
conservatives i am allegedly not
affected by loudoun county policies
which means i should not have involved
myself in loudoun county issues and yet
democrats from other states who are not
affected by texas laws can still involve
themselves in texas issues
those are the rules as we have seen
and those rules freed up the democrats
for the sickening and theatrical
spectacle yesterday
one democrat after another along with
abortionists and others who were called
in to testify
took turns in the spotlight
extolling the beauty and wonder of
dismembering babies they were effusive
in their praise of abortion which is for
them the highest sacrament the holy of
holies the most sacred of sacred rituals
one of the abortionists uh called to
testify actually made this point pretty
clear listen
sb-8 has not only caused a near total
abortion ban in texas it has made it
extremely dangerous to be pregnant in
texas
where our maternal morbidity and
mortality rate is already unconscionably
high especially for black women and
pregnant people of color
texas deserves better
i know first hand that abortion saves
lives for the thousands of people i've
cared for abortion is a blessing
abortion is an act of love abortion is
freedom
we need federal protection now we need
laws that elevate science and evidence
and recognize the dignity and autonomy
of people accessing care what a ghoul
what a
absolute demon
she says abortion is a blessing it's an
act of love freedom
but love for who exactly freedom from
what
well love for oneself presumably
and uh freedom from your child from your
responsibilities she's correct at least
in one sense abortion is an act of
self-love it is in some ways the
ultimate act of self-love because you
are prioritizing your own comfort
convenience and lifestyle above all else
above even your own child we'll have
more on this concept of self-love in the
daily cancellation at the end of the
show
abortion is the high sacrament of
leftism because leftism is a religion of
the self it is the worship of the self
which is to say that it is satanism so
there's there's a certain truth there
but as for the freedom that's illusory
at best a woman can kill her child to be
free of the responsibilities of
parenthood but she'll she'll never
really be free
abortion kills the child it doesn't
erase the fact that the child ever
existed
doesn't turn the clock back
so while she's free from the
responsibilities of motherhood she will
have substituted the strain of those
responsibilities with the crushing
burden of guilt heartbreak and grief for
the rest of her life
even
women who are pro-abortion and
post-abortive
will admit to this and yet they speak of
freedom
it's not freedom it is rather trading
one burden for another and the new
burden is much worse than the one you
were trying to escape
and then there was uh the ancient
feminist gloria steinem who testified by
video apparently streaming via camcorder
from the year 1994
and steinem used her time to point out
that hey you know hitler also banned
abortion coincidence she thinks not
that's why what's happening in texas is
not only a local issue or a women's
issue it's a step against democracy
which allows us to control
our own bodies and our own voices
remember when hitler was elected
and he was elected
his very first official act was to
padlock the family planning clinics and
declare
abortion a crime against the state
mussolini did exactly the same thing
because they knew that controlling
reproduction
and nationalizing women's bodies is the
first step in a controlling state an
all-controlling state
the huge majority of american women
stand for democracy and in opposition to
texas senate bill 8 we do not want to
have our bodies nationalized
so texas making its own laws is an
attack on democracy but congress trying
to
erase or undermine those laws
uh from the federal position is
not
but she says hitler banned abortion and
i guess that means that pro-lifers are
nazis of course hitler was also a
conservationist he was also an
environmentalist which means that
they're all nazis too and hitler
confiscated guns which makes the gun
control crowd nazis hitler also
sometimes from from what i understand
would eat cereal for breakfast that's
this this casts sinister new light on
anybody who's ever had a bowl of fruity
pebbles
as for hitler's abortion policies
steinem is leaving out an important
detail
hitler banned abortion
for ethnic germans
he didn't want babies of the master race
to be killed but he felt very different
about babies of the undesirable races
for them he encouraged abortion or even
mandated it
you see hitler believed in eugenics so
did margaret sanger the founder of
planned parenthood
the hitler abortion comparison cuts
against the pro-abortion crowd because
they in fact share many of his attitudes
towards the procedure consider the fact
that hitler and pro-abortion people in
america in the year 2021
have the exact same attitude about
disabled babies in the womb
the vast majority of down syndrome
babies are aborted in some western
countries down syndrome people have been
almost entirely exterminated
hitler had the same approach to the same
group of people
he looks up from hell to the
pro-abortion lobby and nods in approval
no doubt looking forward to the day when
the people in that lobby will be joining
him speaking of which ayanna presley
shared her thoughts at the hearing as
well and uh one thing you know about her
you gotta give her credit for this she
always stays on message listen
these misguided bands will not actually
prevent all abortions they simply put
safe and necessary abortion care out of
reach for our most vulnerable
specifically our lowest income sisters
our queer trans and non-binary siblings
black latinx aapi immigrants disabled
and indigenous indigenous folks and none
of this is happenstance it is precise
like the roots of the anti-abortion
movement these bans are rooted in
patriarchy and white supremacy
always on message yes queer trans and
non-binary people are especially hurt by
anti-abortion laws
this claim is never explained mostly
because it is apt abject nonsense
but ayanna presley simply
cannot give her opinion on any subject
or talk about anything at all without
giving this list of special protected
identities i'm sure she's in like the
drive-through line at wendy's going yes
i along with the members of the trans
non-binary queer indigenous bipark
polyamorous and latinx communities would
like to order a frosty
so you want a frosty for all those
people or just yourself i'm confused
but out of everyone rashida talib
probably won the oscar for best actress
actress at the hearing yesterday talib
has taken on in recent times more of
sort of the the ringo position in the
squad the forgotten member she doesn't
get the same press that used to be the
case for ayanna presley but it seems
there's been a reshuffling within the
squad which is really interesting
leaving rasheeda to leave out on the
outskirts and i think she tried to
rectify that yesterday listen to this
you know i i grew up in the most
beautiful blackest city in the country
where 85 percent of the city of detroit
is black and it's beautiful and black
mothers are the ones who told my mother
to raise her voice when she had that
heavy immigrant like accents at parent
meetings
and you know i'm sitting there listening
to people pretending disingenuously
honestly that they actually care about
the lives of my black neighbors
i always get emotional about this
because i cannot believe
that my colleagues who didn't vote for
the george floyd justice for policing
act are talking about the fact that
planned parenthood which i believe is
literally one of the only health care
places and institutions like cities like
mine
the fact that
we have some of the worst infant
mortality rates in the country among
black children
we can't even get them to one years old
it's like why are we spending the same
energy
doctor and saving those lives getting
them to one year how come when i was in
the michigan legislature they spent so
much time on this that they never wanted
to talk about that single mother that we
needed to make sure that she had the
wrap around services okay first of all i
can't take you seriously if you start by
claiming detroit is beautiful detroit is
about as beautiful as a highway rest
stop bathroom as for the rest of it
talib says she's worried about infant
mortality she wants to make sure that we
get
babies to one year old and the best way
to do that is to kill them intentionally
in the womb apparently
this is the kind of argumentation you
get from that side
here's just a little bit more from talib
now this is about controlling women in
our country period stop pretending it's
anything but
you know what's so distressful about all
of this is the fact that it's not just
texas chairwoman you know this this is
gonna this is literally opening the
floodgates to the possibility that we
are actually going to
see our country
punish and criminalize abortion
criminalize women making a very
difficult decision
it would be funny if it weren't so gross
to watch these ranting scowling
women
pretend that there's some higher nobler
reason for their rage this is about
controlling women they shout
which even if that were the case these
megalomaniacs have no problem
controlling people women or otherwise
when it comes to most any other issue
they even have no problem making
decisions about a woman's body as we've
seen
with the vaccine and the mask mandates
but of course it isn't true and they
know that it has nothing to do with
controlling women they know that also
they they they understand and as was
said early on
you know this is about
the elevation of the self this is about
putting the self above all things and
the more these people talk
the more hearings they give
i think the better it is for our side
because the more they reveal what really
lies underneath
all of this
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
if you're one of the millions of
americans male or female who deals with
bags and puffiness under the eyes well
let me tell you about genusell serum
from chamonix genusl serum uses plant
cell technology to promote visibly
healthier skin and the appearance of
younger healthier eyes genusell's state
of the art technology will become your
most powerful weapon against under eye
bags and puffiness customers everywhere
have been raving about this product i've
been raving about it not only that but
my assistant tessa has been using genusl
for a couple of weeks i just think it's
funny to say it's like i'm using my i'm
using my assistant as a as you know some
sort of lab rat experimenting um that's
not what's happening at all but genusl's
actually great it's a great product it
really is and i've had many
conversations with tessa about genusl
and we both agree that it is fantastic
with its instant effects you'll see
results in the first 12 hours or your
money back they guaranteed so order now
and save big on genusel's risk-free
introductory offer all orders are up to
50 off go to genusell.com and enter
mat30 for an extra 30 off today that's
genusell.com genusell.com
you know uh i think i'm usually pretty
low maintenance but there have been a
couple of incidents recently where i've
had these uh i don't know prima donna
moments i guess
uh like last night heading to my my
speaking event here in memphis security
came to pick me up and i realized i
forgot to pack a tie and i was a keynote
speaker at a fundraising banquet
so i asked them to take me somewhere
like on the way so that i could get one
and we went to to a walmart because you
know that's i mean that's of course
really really classy and it was the
closest thing nearby to the venue
and uh the security guys were there
walking through walmart and we're
walking around the men's section and
apparently they don't sell ties at
walmart that's that was a revelation for
me so then they said there's a men's
warehouse nearby and it's okay let's go
to the men's warehouse and we were
already late at this point
and security guy came in with me and we
went into the men's warehouse i had to
ask him what color my shirt was and he
helped me match a tie
um and uh finally i bought one and we're
late to the event at this point and i
missed they're supposed to be a meet and
greet and i missed it and we had to do
it after
because i was getting a tie but then as
we as we pulled up i looked and i
realized that um it was a more casual
event than i thought and so i said never
mind i'm not gonna wear the tie so it
was all of that and i didn't even wear
it
and uh you know so you you have little
moments like that but i think i think
for the most part i'm i'm pretty still
pretty low maintenance guy
all right so we've been playing uh
a lot of clips from this from this
hearing
from the bad guys
and i don't mean to oversimplify it but
i mean it really is that simple they're
just they they're the bad guys and when
when when this is what you're you're
standing for and this is what you're
this is what you're enraged about is
that we're going to be killing fewer
babies then you're that's the bad guy
side and there's a very clear line that
we can draw there so we played some of
the bad guy eclipse there's one other
clip i wanted to play for and i'm saving
it for here
because representative burgess owens
he's on the good side
he uh in the midst of all of this
lunacy he interjected with
i'm trying to stop myself from using the
phrase truth bombs because i hate that
phrase
but i'll allow it here just this one
time it's the only time you'll ever hear
me say it
because i think these really are if
anything qualifies as a truth bomb then
then this actually is listen to what he
has to say
i think we're gonna ever get to
resolving the issues we have in in the
black community we gotta be honest my
friends
uh we just heard that uh
a pushback on the fact that we're
getting black men and black community
not doing their job well let me give you
the facts real quick first of all
when i was growing up in the 60s we led
the country and then committed to
marriage over 70 percent
black women could could could rely on
getting married more than white men
until white women until 1970.
we now have between 70 to 80
of black fathers who deserve their
families and we're not willing to be
honest about that
we're not willing to say that these
these guys need to man up
maybe when we start telling
when we start telling our our kids
that they're being nothing but whiners
wings and wimps if men cannot take care
of their own kids
that might be a good start i ain't
rejecting the word let me please mr
chairman i i call for orders
we right now the facts are important
it's the big says the time the facts are
in facts
black fathers
70 to 80 percent are deserting their
families you talk to tell these black
single women out there and see what they
think about this we see this little
bubble
where we're living the life
we were married many of us
and we cannot be honest about what's
happening in our urban communities
while these kids are growing up with no
fathers no exam solutions at the end of
the day there's a reason why our kids
are being
led toward this this these options of
hopelessness
and for us to sit here and 2021 no no
not right now i'm sorry let me just
finish to sit here in 2021
and not point out the fact that we have
fatherless homes
we have seventy to eighty percent these
are the facts my friends
seven eighty percent will not marry the
mothers of their children and instead
would probably try to convince them so
they to dissolve them from their issues
to go and get an abortion
we've lost 20 million black babies of
the last 40 years
40
of my race has been exterminated
because we don't have men
yeah i want i wanted to play as much of
that clip as i could it wasn't even the
whole the whole thing goes on for
another few minutes and uh i think it's
i think it's great it two things are
great about it and very instructive and
revealing
uh the one is what he's saying but also
you hear the woman i'm not even sure
which which congresswoman that is but
frantically trying to cut in as i object
to this language that's being used
he actually says well we've got to take
responsibility to care for our families
i object to that language this is
offensive i can't believe what's being
said
can i could i are you finished can i
could i just
they're they're so terrified to have
that coverage they don't want to have
this conversation at all
about taking responsibility for yourself
and your own families
they don't want to talk about the state
of the family
in the black community and across the
country
and how that ties into
all of our problems every single problem
that we're having societally speaking
every single one
can be traced
uh in large part back to the collapse of
the family
this is no great secret
and it shouldn't require any courage to
point it out
and i shouldn't be so impressed that
there's a
someone in congress making this point
because it's so obvious
you you can't have a society
without the
family you know we've got we've got
thousands of years
of history to look at
with human civilization
and we can look out throughout the world
throughout history every single
civilization that's ever existed on the
planet every human civilization
and there's never been one
that has tried to do it without the
family structure
at the foundation of it
it can't happen you can't do it
because that that is that is the
fundamental building block for for
everything else everything else rests
upon the family
and if you abandon the family
there's there's nothing else that can
come in and sufficiently take its place
that's the experiment that we are
conducting right now
especially in the cities can we get rid
of the family say we don't need the
family and have the government come in
and and uh and take over that
responsibility you know we don't need me
we don't need fathers to be the
breadwinners and the providers and the
protectors the government we can do that
we can put them on the social programs
and put them on the welfare programs
um and we you know we have a bunch of
cops there and and you know so we will
fill out with provider protector we fill
all those roles
as the government
so we have watched this
experiment
play out in the cities for decades
and to put it mildly it has not worked
i mean it's been a catastrophe it has
been an apocalyptic catastrophe
that's why when you walk through cities
today it looks like a literal
apocalyptic wasteland you're walking
through
and all that you're seeing there that is
the debris
of the nuclear family which has
collapsed
in the cities and also across the
country increasingly
fatherless homes are a problem
uh across the country people are
abandoning marriage abandoning nuclear
family i mean this is this is a social
trend
that you find everywhere
um
now
the fact that this is happening and the
consequences of it
are inescapable
and the democrats know that and so
they're they're only
there's nothing they could say in
response to it
so instead they just try to ignore it
and they they always deflect and say no
let's look over there look let's no no
no no we don't need to talk about let's
talk about guns let's let's talk if
there's if there are you know young men
in the cities running around shooting
each other for no reason
uh
let's talk about how they got their hand
their hands on those guns that's the
problem
let's not discuss
why those young men would want to behave
that way in the first place what went so
horribly wrong
in their upbringing in their home lives
that if they have guns they're just
going to go out and shoot each other for
no reason
let's not talk about that part of it no
no let's just discuss the gun so that's
what democrats want to do and if someone
sits there especially some burgers owen
burgess owens a black man uh if if he
sits there and talks about this they get
very angry and they they don't want to
discuss it and that tells you everything
you need to know
in fact at one point i think she
actually said she said something like
well what are your solutions
you're not you're not coming up with any
solutions
yeah he is
he gave the solution
that's the solution was
take fathers take care of your families
you know when you have kids
get married preferably before you have
the kids
um but worst case after if that's what
if that's what you need to do
and uh and then and and and stay with
your kids and raise them that's the
solution
have kids
a woman and man have kids they stay in
the same house
and they raise those kids
that's the solution
if you're saying well give us a solution
besides that
let's not do that and think of a
different solution there isn't one there
is no other solution there is no plan b
because they've been looking for a plan
b for decades and they haven't found one
so if we're giving up on the family then
we're then we just we've given up on
society we've given up on civilization
there's no point even talking about any
of this stuff just forget about it
there's no point we've given up
let it all collapse and we'll we'll all
live in the ruins i guess
if you want a real solution
it has to begin there yeah there are
other things we can do
it's not like if we have a strong
nuclear family in in america that we're
going to live in a utopia there's still
going to be other problems we have to
fix but we've got to start there
have kids stay at home with them
if we're ruling that out if you're not
going to do that then
then there's no hope then we are
hopeless at that point
so it's this or it's nothing
all right here's a cbs report about the
national school board association asking
for biden's help to stop the domestic
terrorists that's their phrase um the
domestic terrorist attacks against them
otherwise known as parents
giving their opinions at school board
meetings here's that report
school board officials are calling for
help tonight
following increasingly violent incidents
like this in minnesota
a man complimenting school board members
during a debate over masks who's then
charged by an unmasked man
writing to president biden the national
school boards association
asked for help investigating the violent
incidents and suggested the fbi monitor
threats to board members likening these
heinous actions to domestic terrorism
the impact of the pandemic on public
schools is creating all this heightened
rhetoric around the nation and
unfortunately in some places it's
leading to threats and actual incidents
of violence
nevada school board member kurt thigpen
said that he resigned after the constant
harassment over email phone and social
media made him think about suicide he
cited the january 6 insurrection as a
trigger for the unruly behavior
they were coming after me and my
colleagues consistently
every day
through multiple mediums they saw me as
a target for their hate white house
responding today to the school board
letter saying that they're looking at
what more the administration can do
obviously these threats to school board
members is
horrible they're doing their jobs
obviously local police are still going
to have a presence at these very
contentious sometimes violent school
board meetings but what school officials
nationwide want is for the feds to
provide some level of intel that will
give them some sense of what kind of
threats are heading their way yeah we
keep hearing about these the heinous
heinous actions at these school board
meetings
violence domestic terrorism
and then uh they show us clips i guess i
mean i'm assuming they're showing us the
worst of it
if there's if there's something worse
they would have showed us that
and the clips for the most part it's
like people yelling and getting upset
and
every once in a while
all these school board meetings across
the country
there have been a couple of cases of of
minor scuffles breaking out
that are broken up and no one is
seriously injured
so this is this is
that
as far as violence goes that's it
a couple of minor scuffles that's it
that's the end of that
and and by the way it's it's not as
though this is entirely on the part of
the conservative parents which is what
we're supposed to take away from this
as you know i have been to some of these
meetings
and uh very often there are people on
the other side as well and then that's
where that's where the arguing and
shouting comes from
so a couple of minor scuffles no one
seriously injured and then outside of
that it's it's mostly just people
getting upset
and uh you know maybe raising their
voices a little bit
and this is a this is a domestic
terrorist crisis we kill we can't have
that
well the real crisis here is that these
people on these school boards that are
that have been so accustomed for years
they've had such a great job where they
get to go in and they go to their
meetings and and really no one in the
public shows up and nobody cares and
they set the policies and they do
exactly what they want and they're
uncontested and um
they have an enormous amount of power
in setting education policy in their
districts deciding what kids are going
to be taught how they're going to be
treated
this enormous power they have
and for years it's like nobody noticed
that they had this power
and finally people are noticing and
they're saying wow you know what those
people on those boards they
they uh they have a significant amount
of control
over my kids and my family really i
think i want to have a say in this
people are the public is noticing
they're going to public meetings and
this is
this is a crisis
because these school boards they can't
they cannot defend
their policies
they can't argue in favor of them
so all they can do is just label you say
you're a domestic terrorist and now
they're going to the biden
administration
and next thing you know we're going to
have um
uh federal
involvement in school boards
and yet again i got to go back and and
to to to the irony here uh in the
hypocrisy of
uh
i go to loudoun county school board and
i'm interfering now the school boards
themselves are going to the federal
government and saying please interfere
so while they're while they're telling
the outsiders the agitators don't come
they are the ones going and getting
outsiders and saying please come here
and stop these these mean people from uh
saying all these these horrible things
about us
i'm sorry i i just don't have any
sympathy i don't want to hear about oh
we got these
we've got death threats we've got
everything for
number one like i always say with death
threats i
i don't believe it until you until you
show me the receipts on that everyone's
always claiming
every time someone
you know is is is being criticized the
public we always get these claims i've
got so many death threats death threats
coming all over the place
i just don't buy it until you like show
it to me that you're actually getting
those death threats or i don't believe
it i think there are a lot of people
just claiming they get death threats
um
and even if you are
that i get death threats as well i know
what that's like it's not fun
i've experienced that
uh
but even if you get death threats that's
not good i don't approve of that
but it doesn't suddenly
vindicate
whatever you were doing that upset
people
all right um
what else we got here oh this is really
important we got it we got to cover this
so demi lovato
as you know i'm a big fan of demi lovato
uh who mostly i think she what is she
non-binary now or no she pansexual
or no lesbian but she's she was lesbian
and then went pansexual and most
recently she's non-binary
so she's been going through this uh this
little bit of transformation
and um
now she has also come out as a believer
in aliens
and so this brings together it's like
two of my worlds are colliding demi
lovato aliens
she's she even has a show now i think
where she goes on on the hunt for
for aliens and here she is on the e news
channel talking about her own
experiences with uh space aliens very
interesting listen
do you believe in ufos uh
well demi lovato does in her new show
unidentified with demi lovato demi drags
their sister and best friend into the
woods to hunt for the unexplained and
they told aaron all about it
what is that oh my goodness wait this is
so gross convince us why we should watch
the show we laughed a lot
and we saw some really interesting
things that we catch on camera i just
have a curiosity about this topic that
i've always
i've always had and
and so i wanted to find out for myself
say hi to night vision
high night vision and you two were
pretty skeptical at first what was the
turning point for you yeah i mean i
identified as a non-believer coming in
and i would say i'm definitely a lot
less of a skeptic than i was before with
all this ufo stuff like
you know being open and being ready to
accept it helps and i think we were and
i think that shows and demi you had an
encounter before shooting the show can
you please give us the details on that
experience we went out into the desert
in joshua tree and i basically saw like
this blue orb that uh
was about 50 feet away
maybe less and
it was just
it was kind of like floating above the
ground just like 10 or 15 feet but was
keeping its distance from me and i don't
know it just um it was really it was a
really beautiful and incredible
experience
yeah i think those might have been the
drugs that you were taking but no i
actually no i i beli listen
i believe you
demi lovato i believe you on this
uh some of the other claims you've made
about yourself i i find a little bit
hard to believe like that you're both
both men and women
all all at once contained within one
person
that part i'm not sure about but
aliens i believe i believe you
i hear you
you are valid
i i just i buy it
and i say that mostly unironically
there there are too many people who have
had these experiences
and how do you how do you explain it all
i mean i guess you know there's a lot of
a lot of potential explanations but none
of them as interesting as the
explanation that we're being visited by
uh space aliens why do they keep coming
here in their in their orbs and then
leaving
it's like coming a long way and then
leaving and then they just they keep
coming you think whatever they were
looking for they would have found by now
and realize that this is not where they
want to be
so i can't explain any of that
i mean in demi lovato's case i guess i
can't explain it
if these uh
these aliens came all this way many
light years and they're they're about to
land on earth
and the first people they see
are demi lovato and her crew
you can't really blame them for saying
never mind guys we made a mistake let's
get out of here
let's go check out jupiter instead
all right let's uh okay one other thing
i think before we get to comments uh
let's see this is from the daily wire
says former tonight show host jay leno
knows comedy having started stand up way
back in the early 1970s but leno says
the recent emergence of cancelled
culture
has changed the rules of comedy
during an appearance this week on the
people every day podcast the 71 year old
comedian said that those who hope to
succeed nowadays will have to adapt
uh leno said i think it's like any other
thing you either change or die
in football you have certain rules and
when the rules change if you don't
conform to them you're out of the game
leno said sexist racist and homophobic
jokes were once considered okay but all
that has changed
now everybody has a voice you said you
have to change the material to the times
you live in
my attitude is look these are the new
rules you want to adapt if you don't
find don't get up and tell jokes then
this is really kind of
amazing to hear from uh a comedian who
said he's he is openly saying that if
you want to be a comedian you have to
conform and follow the rules
now silly me i thought that the point of
of comedy was
exactly the opposite of that
especially if you're in the business of
being a stand-up comedian
your your job is to find all of the
societal rules and the things that
people are conforming to
and you break those rules on purpose
you point out the absurdity of them
that might not be the the the single
thing that comedy does but it's one of
comedy's most important functions
and i think it's actually it is an
important thing for society we need that
i actually believe that comedians have
performed a valuable service
in our country
in the past anyway
by pointing to finding these uh these
sacred cows these elephants in the room
that nobody talks about and pointing to
the elephant and saying look at that
elephant isn't that funny like that that
we you need that in society i think and
you're also holding powerful people
accountable
uh but now we have comedians saying oh
no here are the rules
you don't want to follow the rules and
conform they just don't tell any jokes
all right let's get now to reading the
comments uh
and let's play the song first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i almost forgot the song but i didn't
this is knit girl says if we are so
influenced by the pictures of a no-name
person on instagram
that companies will pay thousands uh so
that said person will peddle their
shampoo on their feed i think it's safe
to say that as a culture we're
influenced by the content we consume we
cancelled our netflix subscription last
november and subscribed to dw with that
money
good good choice
i've encouraged several others in my
little circle to do the same little by
little there's a response i guess to our
conversation we had about uh the squid
game
show on netflix right now the most
popular show on netflix
uh there are some other perspectives on
that though joshua gibbons says i think
that article about squid game was
completely over the top it's nowhere
near that focused on gore as it implies
saw is far worse it might not be your
type of cup of tea
or your tup of key totally fine but i
won't really call squid game torture
porn it doesn't really focus on the gore
though it does have it and its general
point is that these things are bad the
focus and squid game is on the
characters the gore is incidental
exactly like you described in saving
private ryan
and hanky hankerson says i respectfully
disagree with your interpretation of
squid game i've only seen the first
episode so far but it's clear just from
that episode that the game and the
violence in the in the game is framed as
an extreme product of the social
economic dysfunction endemic in north
korea the korean economy is a highly
competitive world with a handful of big
winners and a large number of distraught
losers the series is a clever critique
of that reality i think you should watch
the first episode then come back to the
to the show
and uh let viewers know what you think
okay yeah i haven't watched it i have no
interest in watching it um
i mean this idea that you can't make any
judgment calls about a show or a movie
without watching it i think is
ridiculous i mean there there are
certainly things where
uh
there are plenty of movies and shows
where you can kind of understand the
basic gist without actually having to
watch it
um i mean i've never watched
the bachelor but i
i i think i'm i'm pretty safe in making
some assumptions about that show which
is why i don't watch it
um as for this i mean this idea that
it's a parody of the social and economic
uh situation in in in korea and across
and across the world
maybe it is
i'm skeptical because i heard that exact
same rationalization with what was that
movie that came out it won all the
oscars
um
it was a parasite
yeah i think that was the one and it's i
heard the same exact thing like a very
violent movie
and uh there are there are scenes that
might seem gratuitous
but it's actually it's it's this this
really clever
uh critique of social inequality and
it's it's a comment on the class system
and class structures and i watch the
movie
with that in mind
and no it's not it's just a
it's
if you if you you could try to turn any
movie into that if you want to
but i didn't see it with parasite i
thought that movie was pretty bad
and with this
maybe but but i'm skeptical i mean again
the point with violence
in a in a in a film
is
you know is it a necessary
part of the story
and like that's why i use saving private
ryan is one of many examples but in a
movie like if you're gonna tell
a story about things that happen in war
if you're going to tell a war story then
violence is a necessary part of that you
take violence out of that and you might
as well not tell the story you can't
tell the story without the violence
because it's a part of it
and i think we can all agree that there
are plenty of stories worth telling um
that have happened in uh in the context
of war
so
that's obviously the case there
um and you just have to ask yourself
with this with this show or any other
is this violence part of the stories of
moving the story forward is it important
and necessary element
or
is it just something for us to gawk at
is the violence an end in itself in the
film or in the show
where at least part of the entertainment
value is simply watching the violence
itself play out there's a lot of that
of course there are a lot of shows like
that a lot of movies like that
not all of them are over the top gory
but i think violence in that context no
matter how gory it is
you know can
can be a problem it's i think it it
that's when it qualifies as gratuitous
um okay
i mean it's the same thing with like
sexual content in a in a in a film i
mean we could all agree that that
romance and love these are important
parts of story sometimes
but very very often
the filmmakers go far beyond that and
they show you things uh that were not
necessary for the story at all and the
only reason they're putting that in
there is for
this is for us to just gawk at so
all right
uh
parva says the great thing about dating
apps is that as a person who approaches
people in person i have almost no
competition well you're right about that
because it's like nobody does that
anymore so
yeah i guess the field is open for you
it's a good strategy
uh jk says hey matt what airline do you
normally fly with whichever one gets me
there the fastest and this has the best
prices i i i don't have any
loyalty to any airline because they're
all pretty terrible
there was a time when maybe you would
say southwest is sort of different but i
think southwest especially with the
masking stuff in recent uh
in recent months has kind of fallen off
so at this point they're all equally as
abysmal so there's no point in even
getting that particular about it
and finally dan says you can't really
blame jada pinkett smith for what she
did she didn't want to do it she cheated
against her will
dan
there are some who would ban you from
the show for that but i will not because
i appreciate a good pun sir so thank you
for that i can still remember when i was
a kid we had uh these things called you
kids don't know about this but we had
these things called photo albums and
that wasn't something on the phone we
didn't have them on the phones phones
were connected to the wall there was no
photos on them uh but it was an actual
book that you would open up and you
would flip through it and there would be
like you'd put physical pictures inside
it
and it's just one of the antiquated
forms of technology we used to use to
and that's where we kept all of our
memories and our cherished you know the
events of the past all there problem is
where are those things now they're in an
attic they're in a basement they're
collecting dust maybe they're you know
they're getting ruined by floods and
everything else that's why you need
legacy box legacy box is your chance to
have aging photographs films tapes
everything digitally preserved so the so
that you have the ability to relive your
family history and it's never lost
because of a leaky pipe or summer days
that make your attic hot enough to melt
tapes plus this week legacy box is
offering 40 off at
legacybox.com so you can start future
proofing your pass today i've used
legacy box myself i cannot recommend it
enough so visit legacybox.com walsh to
take advantage of this limited time
offer from 40 off take advantage of this
exclusive offer today and then use their
kit whenever you're ready that's
legacybox.com walsh to say 40 off
legacybox.com walsh let's get now to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
there are days when it's hard to find
something to cancel well that's not
exactly true i mean there are always
millions of options but today the
cancellation presents itself to me
taking the decision out of my hands
entirely
i have no choice but to cancel this this
is an op-ed just published in the new
york times written by a professor at the
university of san francisco school of
law named lara balzone
and the title is divorce can be an act
of radical self-love
the professor begins i used to believe
that divorce is a terrible thing
particularly when children are involved
growing up i absorbed cultural tropes
about absent fathers and efficiency
apartments mothers struggling to support
themselves awful step parents and
unwanted step siblings to this day
divorce is portrayed as precarious and
grim
well yes it is portrayed that way
because it is that way
but the professor says that she has a
she has had a revelation and she sees it
differently now she continues but i've
learned that divorce can also be an act
of radical self-love that leaves the
whole family better off my divorce
nearly seven years ago freed me from a
relationship that was crushing my spirit
it freed my children then five and three
from growing up in a profoundly
unhealthy environment
and then you know amid all of the
disingenuous rationalizations
she said something shockingly honest she
says quote
there was no emotional or physical abuse
in our home there was no absence of love
i was in love with my husband when we
got divorced part of me is in love with
him still i suspect that will always be
the case even now after everything when
he walks into the room my stomach drops
the same way it does before the roller
coaster comes down i divorced my husband
not because i didn't love him i divorced
him because i loved myself more
now i want to focus on that last
sentence there
but first
let's just read how she wraps all this
up first she writes quote
talking to the subset who are divorced i
found a common theme even a sisterhood
divorce is painful and heartbreaking but
it can also be liberating pointing the
way toward a different life that leaves
everyone better off including the
children i no longer think of divorce as
shameful or feel sorry for people who
tell me that they have decided to end
their marriages there are many ways a
family can be broken sometimes the
healthiest decision is to remove the
cracking shell of the nuclear family
before the shards embed themselves in
the precious little people nestled
inside my divorce spared my children
that pain and let me live the life that
i was meant to i view that as an
accomplishment
now in between that final paragraph and
the bit about loving herself more
she explains that the reason for the
divorce was her own refusal to put her
marriage and family before her career
career
she was always primarily focused on her
job even when she was at home and she
doesn't say that in a reflective or
remorseful way she's proud of the ways
that she neglected her children and her
spouse and she's even prouder of
wrecking her marriage and destroying her
family this is all an accomplishment she
says
she claims as these people always do
that it's been better for the kids
and you can tell that she doesn't really
believe that it doesn't care anyway you
know she doesn't love her kids all that
much at least she doesn't love them as
much as she loves herself she makes that
clear her kids barely figure into the
story at all
she simply waves them away with a few
lines about how they're doing well and
they're super happy about this broken
home situation
divorce people will often tell this kind
of story about how the kids are better
off what they mean is that the kids have
adapted
um they've they've made the best of the
circumstances and they've internalized a
lot of the pain and trauma of what
you've done to them that's the kind of
better off we're talking about
often i'll hear and the author makes a
similar case that hey the kids are
better off with divorced parents than
with parents who are miserable and angry
and fighting all the time and creating
an emotionally and psychologically
tumultuous environment at home okay but
why are those the two options
i mean yeah if you say the kid to the
kids listen you can either have divorced
parents or you could have parents who
are awful to each other every day and
screaming at each other and pitting you
guys against each other
if you present those options maybe lots
of kids would choose the former
but what about the option where mom and
dad grow up a little
and stop thinking about themselves so
much
and go out and get the counseling they
need and fight for their family and
their marriage and stay together that
way
why has that been taken off the table
and if you've taken it off the table
stop saying the kids are better off
they're better off arguably
between these two false and bad options
you've given them
but this won't this woman has enough
honesty and self-awareness to admit the
truth she loves herself more
she doesn't say it like it's in a
mission she's proud of it
she she has
the wrong view of her own radical
self-love but she has at least
identified the real point she loves
herself more and indeed no marriage can
work that way no family can function
when the people who are supposed to be
keeping it together are primarily
focused on their own comfort and
well-being marriage is the radical
giving of the self to another it is a
radical act of love outward love you
cannot give yourself to another while
prioritizing yourself over the other as
this woman has discovered
now i say that she's right to identify
her self-love as the source of her
marital disintegration but really
self-love probably isn't the right term
you know it's a bit of an oxymoron if
anything love after all is a choice it's
a thing you do
it's an act of sacrifice
affection is a feeling love is an
activity so how can you really love
yourself sacrificially how can you
sacrifice for yourself
if it's for yourself then it's not a
sacrifice by definition
it seems that when people talk about
loving themselves what they mean is
either conjuring warm feelings about
themselves which is not love
or they mean simply putting themselves
first before everyone else which is just
selfishness
the word love doesn't belong in either
scenario love is inherently outward
it goes out from within to lift up and
elevate the other
love that goes out and comes back like a
boomerang to elevate the lover herself
is again selfishness
so let's not sully a noble word like
love by associating it with that
so this woman has chosen selfishness
over love over her family over her
marriage
she claims to be happy with the choice
for now and maybe she is for now
but if she has any sort of conscience at
all
then she already has at least some quiet
moments home alone after work where the
loneliness sets in
she feels deeply isolated by her own
selfishness wonders what any of this
striving and effort and career ambition
is really worth when she's doing it just
for herself
those moments will become more frequent
less quiet as she grows older and older
and she'll no doubt find other people to
blame but that's not going to change
anything or relieve her misery
and i know that it will play out this
way because it always does it's
inevitable
when people prioritize themselves above
all else when they live lives of
selfishness they eventually get exactly
what they wanted
just themselves alone isolated
no one to love or be loved by
it's how the story always ends
that's why it's better to choose love
real love outward sacrificial love
that's also why the writer of this
article lara belzone
is today cancelled
and that'll do it for us today and for
the week have a great weekend everybody
talk to you monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin